foreign
[Music]
um
someone John 3
yep
uh it's on booster and he's drunk
rules
hey Anthony you got your gun on you
is it anywhere in the car it's in my bag
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
I wonder if everything was okay
real quick
[Music]
I need to check you out you guys
anything like that yeah
on Battle soon
whatever you guys have to do I guess
you guys good
let's look over here
are you having a drink yeah
come on
how much
stuff
coming into work
no
sleep
[Music]
for a while so
it's pretty comfortable coming along
[Music]
passes
I am not coming to work come on
I have core here like five hours okay
where are you coming from
the car area
all right
swing out for a second okay
let me say
what's up what do you say
um
we're waiting on Shane and then we'll go
from there okay
we're good
when's the last time you ate anything
when's last time you had your last drink
what time
sure
yep
all right Anthony you know a drill okay
it came up protect a note of an
alcoholic beverage that he made the
drinking
so we got to do what we got to do some
unfortunate circumstance but
I don't enjoy it any more than you do
so at this time I would offer you to
perform field sobriety test
would you like to perform them or are
you going to look at this
okay
grab my clipboard we're going to go
behind the car okay
so we can agree this is probably a
pretty even ground right yeah okay I'm
gonna have you stand right here and face
this direction for me
do you have any medical issues
anything with knees ankles hips
okay
all right
the first steps we're gonna do is a walk
and turn you're going to place your left
foot on the line you can use the yellow
line right here
you're going to place your right foot on
the line ahead of your left foot with
your heel of your right foot against
your left
excuse me
with the heel of your right foot against
toe of your left foot
so right foot on the line
ahead of the left foot
right foot online yep and then your
your left foot in front of your right
foot
let's go do that for me right now okay
yep
all right place your arms down your side
maintain this position until I've
completed the instructions do not start
look to walk until told to do so you
understand the instructions so far okay
when I tell you to start take nine Heel
To Toe steps turn and take nine Heel To
Toe steps back
Mr step so we're going to place your
arms down your side I'm going to go back
to step three okay
so we're going to place your right foot
down left foot in front maintain this
position with your arms down your side
maintain this position until I've
completed the instructions do not start
to walk until told to do so you
understand
I'm gonna tell you to start take nine
Heel To Toe steps turn and take nine
Heel To Toe steps back
when you turn keep the front foot on the
line and turn by taking a series of
small steps with the other foot like
this
so we're here I'm gonna do three you're
gonna do nine
one two
three
okay
series of small steps
one two three again I did three you're
gonna do nine
while you're walking keep your arms down
your sides watch your feet at all times
and count your steps out loud
once you start walking don't stop until
you've completed the test you understand
the instructions sir begin and count
your first step from Heel To Toe
position as one
two
three four five six seven eight nine
one two three four five six seven eight
five okay
face me
next one is a one leg stand please stand
with your feet together and your arms
down your side like this
do not start to perform the test until I
tell you to do so you understand the
instructions so far okay when I tell you
to start raise one leg either leg with
the foot approximately six inches six
inches off the ground keep your raised
foot parallel to the ground
you must keep both legs straight arms at
your side
while holding that position count out
loud in the following manner one
thousand and one one thousand and two
one thousand and three until you're told
to stop
so I'm going to demonstrate for you
I'm going to raise my right foot you can
raise either foot approximately six
inches off the ground arms down on my
side maintaining uh looking at my the
toe 1001 1002 1003 all the way until I
tell you to stop
keep your arms down your side at all
times and keep watching the raised foot
you understand
maybe again
2003 1004 1005 2006 2007 1008 1009 2010
2011 2012.
13 2014 2015 2016 2017 2018
2010. you're good
sorry horizontal gaze of sagmus okay
watch tip my pen
follow with your eyes and your eyes only
okay
and go up
one more time
so I've seen the back of my car for a
second okay
but the eyes
all right
so right now you'll probably cost to
believe that you're operating vehicle
onto the influence of alcohol okay you
are under the rest you're right to
remain silent and you say quinoa used to
be used to get you in the quarter wall
get the right to an attorney if you
cannot afford one won't be appointed by
the courts give the right to answer my
questions anytime without enter your
present you also have the right to stop
answering my question anytime during the
present do you understand your rights
okay go ahead and hop out
gotta put your name in cows take it back
to our police department and then I'll
give you an opportunity to provide a
breast sample okay
I said I don't enjoy this any more than
you do but
it's an unfortunate situation
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
treatment
[Music]
I'll have her call off their rotation
then we go back and yeah we'll just do
that do you mind doing that
yeah maybe chill off your rotation well
um foreign
should we do an inventory of it did you
do an inventory I didn't yeah okay do
you see any personal things in there do
you need anything out of any of their
audio you need do you have anything that
you need out of there
what'd you say
your phone where's your wallet is it in
there too
okay
[Music]
no we'll decide and release you
I don't usually take people to jail for
OVI
it's good if I leave for the toe sheet
and the keys and then we can go back and
get it started yeah I got his I got a
there's a magazine loaded with a wallet
another wallet and then his cell phone
and I figured
yeah
I don't know I didn't see a service
weapon in here he said it's back he's
locked to the community yeah he says
yeah
all right we're gonna have you wait for
our tow truck so we can go back and get
this over with okay
the one from Lachlan
you want to have her just put that back
in the CD
so there's no guns so there's really no
offense as far as the magazine goes
all right we got your phone your wallet
and then I took your house keys off your
car keys okay
is there anything else you need out of
there
one mail from my location back to my PE
real quick